Speaker 1: All right. This is going to be a
segment of contrasts. We are going to really take
a tour through the full milieu of the American
political culture. We're going to start with
President Joe Biden. We're then going to move to
failed former President Donald Trump. And then
we're going to hear from some current supporters
of the failed former President Donald Trump. And
I think you will see that this will really put on
display the full panoply of what is going on in
American politics right now. Now, I want to start
with Joe Biden. And I have to tell you, I love the
new Joe Biden. It doesn't mean I agree with him on
all policy. And there's so many things I wish he
would do that he hasn't done, but he has done many
things in the last three months. But what I really
love about the new Joe Biden is he is doing what
Gavin Newsom said has to happen. We can't just
be meek on the left. We have to come out swinging
because we're right on the issues and we have the
moral high ground. These are deeply delusional,
dangerous, unthinking people on the right.
And Gavin Newsom said Democrats have to point that
out. And increasingly, Biden is doing it okay. A
heckler, a Biden spoke in Milwaukee, Wisconsin
over the weekend and a heckler flipped out and
started screaming as often happens. And Biden
actually says, no, no, no, let him go. By the way,
if it were at a Trump rally. Well, we'll talk
about that in a moment. But then Biden says,
listen, LEAHY Everybody is entitled to be an.
Speaker 3: Idiot and it's not high five man
from the bottom of my heart, as I said last week.
We remain in the battle for the soul of America.
By the way. All right. God love
you. Let him go. Let him go.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. Don't let him go. God.
Speaker 1: Hey, remember when this
happened at a Trump rally? Trump
would go get them the hell out of here.
Speaker 3: Look, everybody's entitled to be
an idiot. No, no. Everybody's out. Okay, good.
Speaker 1: So anyway. Yeah, I mean, at a Trump
rally, the heckler would be beaten to a pulp.
And then Trump would say that he will pay the
attacker's legal bills and then wouldn't actually
pay them. He would offer to pay. Well, you know,
Trump doesn't really pay legal bills, but he
would offer to do that. Also during the speech,
Biden refers to the MAGA people as the
Trump BS, which I think is the perfect
combination of condescending and emasculating.
Speaker 3: But all kidding aside. We we did find
no complaints. We did fine. But here's the point.
The biggest contrast. From what meager Republicans
the extreme right the the the the Trump is.
Speaker 1: Yeah
I kind of like Trump is better than Trumpists
because sometimes when I say Trumpists, people
hear trumpets and that's not what I'm saying.
And then lastly, here's a new little bonus from
Joe Biden making fun of himself for being old.
Speaker 3: And as I said, I just signed into
law Historic Inflation Reduction
Act. It wasn't easy. Take
on big drug companies. But
we did. I've been fighting
them since I got in Congress 180 years ago.
Speaker 1: Anyway, listen, I. I like this.
This is what Newsome was talking about. It can't
be only this. It has to be paired with legislative
accomplishments and a strong economy. And we have
both of those things right now. But this is what
Gavin Newsom was talking about. I just didn't
necessarily expect it to come from the nearly 80
year old Joe Biden. But I welcome it. I just ask.
Where on earth has this Joe Biden been for roughly
the last year and a half? So that was Biden over
the weekend. Now to contrast it. Let's go to Trump